Hopkins must be through security by now
Rosa promised us three minutes tops
we'll get the phone captain Holt's can
you distract a lot of Turner
I'm not captain holt I'm Joe Wozniak
here to see my girl in prison and to
help me pass as straight
Kevin's ruse sharing that are you ready
for this one
daddy's daughter Anna's getting divorced
hate to say I told you so but I told you
so
you know we should fix her up with
Bernice his son what's his name - dr. o
Vince and he's not a doctor is a
pharmacist although that might appeal to
an kid and who should we fix him up with
her oh now sell you know I'm still
getting over the tragic loss of my wife
she was such a strong female woman with
nice heavy breasts who's that oh that's
my neighbor hey Larry
ah hey Greg Greg ah that was it
Lester oh I have so much trouble
remembering probably because our
relationship is so casual morning ladies
hi oh I'll do it laughs without me I
need to talk to Larry about an issue
with our shared fence Larry I need to
talk to you about an issue with our
shared fence yes I also need to discuss
this shared fence issue with you okay
they're out of earshot why are you up so
early
no reason just excited to face a new day
oh because ever since we've been down
here you've been a little depressed have
I
don't eat the burrito I'm just trying to
work up the nerve to see her see who my
female wife crystal I was cheating on
her with a waitress from winged [ __ ]
named jamie-lynn one night when I was
philandering Cristal caught me kissing
jamie-lynns heavy breasts she flew into
a rage and now she's serving five years
for aggravated assault
okay I'm sorry to hear that yeah thanks
man hey bring it in that's a gun
our own
[Music]
pretty please more let's sugar on top
more you should have seen Jamie Lynn she
looked exactly like Maxim Hot 100
honoree Jasmine Sanders five seconds on
the download it just seems like you want
to be with Jamie Lee I mean you keep
talking about a thigh gap that's my
favorite part of a woman there's nothing
more intoxicating than the clear absence
of a penis
but you're right I need to forget about
crystal thanks for the advice I'm off to
plow my mistress so I marched in there
and I told him I wanted that assistant
manager position I wish my son had your
backbone then he could finally divorce
Emily what does he see in her anyway
probably her breasts which are heavier
than average I don't mean to be crude
ladies but that's just out of straight
mind works oh hey Larry
hello groot Greg hey is there an issue
with our shared fence that we must
discuss no our share fence is fine just
off to work there's something going on
at the APD luck yes having a sale on big
ol Springs Chuck's right I knew that
that's just dumbing it down for you at
any rate I am Hong Kong I don't know
where the horn is
look at us three rogue cops taken on a
case the Commissioner told us to drop my
W jacket set up straight
judge Mendell has a reputation for being
strict and proper all right no worries
I'll just act like you say something so
I can get the cadence of your voice down
I will not perfect I will not I will not
I will not have a seat detective I will
not excuse me sorry I meant out of
respect I will choose to stand sit I
will not this looks like it was built
out by a toddler now we're going to have
to go through this point by point
justice cannot be rushed but could it be
gently nudged into hyperspeed I take it
you're the toddler mm excuse me a moment
to me this is going terribly new plan
I'm gonna charm her Oh No
I'm sorry I had to take that you got to
do what you got to do
pepper Raymond Holt what's up
we can't just waltz in there buy
whatever we want they'll do a federal
background check on Rick Stickney and
Larry sherbert and that will set off
alarms in the marshal's office no we'll
have to bribe the gun store owner so he
doesn't run our names but we don't have
any money
oh my god I'm the bribe aren't I you're
not the bride why what's wrong with my
body actually I borrowed $3,000 for my
walking group friend Ruth Ruth I'm gonna
be straight with you I accidentally
knocked up a woman Rob you know me I see
a pair of thick weighty breasts and all
logic flies out the window heterosexual
you is such a dog it's funny when we
first met we had some good times
[Music]
looks like we both want that stapler
seems that way based on what happened so
when did it all go south 1989 that was
up for a big promotion which would have
fast-tracked my career launch offered to
write a letter on my behalf but instead
she torpedoed me because of something
that happened the night before she was
to turn it in Madeline would you care
for a drink I'd love one
I'm sure you can tell I'm quite drunk
I've had a couple that build up the
nerve I think we both know what I'm
about to say Raymond I don't think we
need to say anything
I'm gay that's what I was going to tell
you well then she sabotage my career
because I refuse to be better
you